valorant is almost back baby we've been
getting more and more team announcements
and one thing is for sure these teams
have their work cut out for them some of
the best players in North America have
been picked up but only one team can
make it to the top so the question is
who will it be
hey y'all it's Liz just a quick plug for
our merch because we have new colors of
my personal favorite touch grass hoodie
it comes in black and like an ivory
slash cream now it's my personal
favorite hoodie I think it's your guyses
too I'm being honest so don't forget to
check out the link in the description
below it seems like I will never stop
talking about the new vzt structure so
sit down relax grab a coffee and snack
and get ready because we have a lot to
go through if you haven't seen my
approximately 1 million videos on the
new VCT structure let me give you the
SparkNotes version next year the VCT
will have a partnered league with 10
teams representing three regions each
the America's EMA and Asia there are 30
teams who don't recognize some that's
totally fine just please trust me on
this one those are all the real teams I
didn't just make up a graphic to trick
you just trust me on this one anyways 30
teams are locked into the partner
program with no threat of relegation as
far as I can tell you may hear the
partner program referred to as
franchising which technically isn't
correct because the teams aren't buying
spots but come see
I don't really know what that means I'm
like the lone American in this Canadian
company I did not come out of the womb
speaking French but just like work with
me on this for the teams that missed out
on one of these spots not all hope is
lost because we have the brand new
Challengers league as a very brief
summary 12 teams will be in the
Challenger circuit up to six get invites
and a minimum of six are determined by
two open qualifiers both held in January
teams from this tier 2 league will
compete in the Ascension tournament a
win means earning a spot in the main VCT
circuit joining the ranks of Sentinels
Cloud 900 thieves and more we don't know
which teams have received direct invites
yet but we do know some orgs that have
at least announced their intention to
compete at the top of my list is G2 you
all might remember the unconfirmed
reports that G2 had a spot in the
partner program but then lost it when
former G2 CEO Carlos was seen partying
with controversial internet figure
Andrew Tate but regardless G2 announced
their roster for the Challenger circuit
in a very tongue-in-cheek Style
[Music]
thank you
please G2 is back
[Music]
the roster consists of former version
one players Penny and Whippy oxy and the
former Titans of early valorant in n a
Shazam and Dapper y'all have been
sleeping on Penny and Whippy I swear to
God and of course I love Shazam and
Dapper and with the addition of oxy this
team is looking nice G2 Rob said this
team was built to prove that haters
wrong such incredible guys will all help
Drive the culture of G2 valorent in
North America the fun is just getting
started Shazam if you're watching this
you made it into my twitch recap this
year I'm in your top two percent of
chatters I would have been one percent
but I got really into the breath of the
wild speed runs this year so um but
still rooting for you not to be outdone
by g2's announcement video Dapper
tweeted this photo of an old gag G2
Pulled Under the sentinel's roster when
he was still on it personally I have
nothing to say about this I'm just going
to stay silent and drink my coffee like
a good little girl and let that one
simmer but what is the rest of Na doing
for Challengers I'm so glad you asked
buckle up for this one Mark meru former
exit founder NCO announced his new
organization M80 with some very familiar
faces the former core of ghost gaming
koala Noob John QT and Nismo are joined
by Xander formerly of version 1 and EU
formerly of NRG if you don't know ghost
gaming from last season in my humble
opinion just based on their performance
and improvements alone they should have
been given a spot in the lcq my
co-worker Niall said on paper I think
they have the favorites for promotion
all of these players have proven that
they can compete at the highest level in
an A and so far based on what I've seen
still waiting for more roster
announcements Shopify rebellion and M80
are the favorites in Ascension obviously
it's still early to say but I think any
team with Nismo has the potential to
looks like FNS Energy's very own agrees
Tsum announced that Corey 7 and gimonde
would remain with the team and be joined
by nature and a returning Haze in a
tweet Hayes simply said Daddy's back
sorry as I was writing this script
oxygen announced their roster including
Mitch Randy Savage and scuba and of
course you all know that I'm a giant
guard fan and the rumors are that techs
will be joining the lineup no
confirmation yet but if this is true the
guard are like everyone else I have
talked about looking stacked all of
these rosters have huge potential I
don't think it'd be fair or right to
rank these teams and say explicitly how
I think they're going to do because
we're entering a new season with new
teams and a new meta by chamber but some
of my favorite players have found homes
that could shake things up I'm not
exaggerating when I say any one of these
teams could take it all I'm not saying
that it's going to be a blood bath right
like they're gonna crawl their way and
one's barely gonna make it out what I am
saying is that every single one of these
teams have their resources and people to
overtake their opponents effectively and
consistently
that is a fancy way of saying winning
over the next few weeks more and more
teams will announce their intentions to
compete in the challengers league and
they will announce the rosters that will
compete for them let's remember this is
not a come one come all only 12 teams
can make it into the Challenger circuit
and only one team can win the Ascension
tournament the stakes are incredibly
high for these teams maybe even higher
than they were before Challengers is a
way to make it into the partner program
that is tier one valorent if they don't
win it's back to square one there are no
special invitations no exceptions with
so few spots given to partner teams it
was only a matter of time before
organizations old and new snapped up
what was the rest of the best and made
their rosters I don't know what will
happen come January what I do know is
the age-old saying we have here in an a
and expect the unexpected
Alabama Alaska Arizona Arkansas
California Colorado Connecticut Oklahoma
Oregon Pennsylvania Rhode Island South
Carolina South Carolina Tennessee Texas
New Jersey is the best of the Fifty
Nifty United States as you name every
state in the USA I haven't done the last
part in so long but I was like he has to
know why it's called Fifty Nifty